كانت أزهار الياسمين تبلغ من العمر 25 عامًا فقط
عندما اكتشفت اكتشافًا مذهلاً ،
وأتذكر أنني وقفت في المرآة
ذات يوم مع أعلى خزان ضلع ، وكان بإمكاني أن
أرى بوضوح أن أحد الثديين كان أكبر
من اثنين من تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية أظهر أن
كل شيء كان على ما يرام
ولكن الحامض دفع أطبائها  لمواصلة
البحث وأجروا التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي
، أشعل الثدي كله تقريبًا السرطان في
جميع أنحاء ثديها الأيسر ،
وقد فاته التصوير الشعاعي للثدي
ليس مثاليًا ، لكن في عام 2022 ، يمكن لأجهزة الكمبيوتر
قراءة صور الثدي الشعاعية الآن أيضًا في جامعة نيويورك ،
وهو برنامج ذكاء اصطناعي أنشأه
الأستاذ  يمكن لكريستوف جاروس اكتشاف
السرطانات في صور الثدي الشعاعية
غير المحسوسة للإنسان ،
وهناك احتمال كبير جدًا أن يحتوي هذا
الجزء من الصورة على السرطان
ولم يراه اختصاصي الأشعة ولكن
أ.
تحب النساء
اللاتي لديهن ثدي أكثر كثافة
عندما نجري تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية على ثدي امرأة أصغر سنًا
، يكون الثدي في التصوير الشعاعي للثدي
أبيض ونحن نبحث  بالنسبة
لشيء أبيض ، فإن الورم الموجود في خلفية بيضاء ،
فكر في الأمر مثل العثور على
كرة ثلجية في عاصفة ثلجية ، يصعب فهم
هذه الأنواع من الأنماط
المعقدة إلى حد ما بالنسبة
للبشر ولا يعاني الذكاء الاصطناعي من هذه المشكلة
أبدًا ، فهو دائمًا ما
يكون  في أفضل حالاته وفي برنامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي أنشأته الأستاذة ريجينا
برزيلاي وطالبها آدم يالا ، تخطو خطوة
إلى الأمام حيث يمكنها تحديد ما إذا كانت المرأة
معرضة لخطر كبير للإصابة بالسرطان في
المستقبل بناءً على تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية في
الوقت الحاضر الذي تنظر إليه
تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية للبروفيسور بارزيلاي
تم تشخيص إصابتها بسرطان الثدي في عام
2014.
لذا فإن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
اخترعه فريقك
قد جربته في صورة الثدي الشعاعية لعام 2012
بعد سنوات
وما أظهره أني في أعلى خطر
للإصابة بسرطان الثدي
لا أحد سيفعله  اسأل أطباء الأشعة ، هل يمكنك
إلقاء نظرة على هذه الصورة لامرأة تتمتع بصحة جيدة وتذكر
ما إذا كانت ستصاب بالسرطان في
غضون عامين أو ثلاثة أعوام ،
لذا فأنت تجلب تقنية الذكاء الاصطناعي إلى
TAS  k أن البشر يمكن أن يفعلوا saurs تفكر في
ما كان سيحدث إذا
وثقت في تلك الصورة الأولى لثديها ،
ولا أعرف ما إذا كنت سأكون هنا اليوم ، وتأمل
أن التكنولوجيا الأفضل في السنوات القادمة
ستعني أن النساء الأخريات لن  يجب أن
يصابوا بأمراض السرطان الخاصة بهم من
أجل الصورة الكبيرة إليزابيث كوهين
جاكسونفيل فلوريدا